oh look at that guys what is going on
horror movies hey guys it's the demon
Welcome to our unbiased camera
comparison between the iPhone 15 Pro Max
s23 Ultra and the pixel 7 Pro and the
reason this is the unbiased test is
because Max actually went out and took a
bunch of photos which none of us have
seen so we're going to be looking at
them and judging which one is the best
so get out a piece of paper and a pen or
your phone play along with us and let us
know your results in the comments all
right let's get into the first one and
this looks like a pretty far range Zoom
portrait shot I definitely like the one
on the left the most the one on the
right there's so much detail that's lost
and the one on the center is just
terrible yep and I agree it's horrible
in the center like look at all the
compression everything like all the
issues like artifacts yeah I definitely
would agree with both of you the one on
the left looks absolutely the best yep
so we all agree that it's the left and
by the way guys this is my friend and a
fan of the channel Johnny he's here with
us to kind of spice it up a little bit
and see what his perspective is so let's
see 15 Pro Max is the one on the left by
far the best in terms of quality and now
we have the next one this looks like a
1x basic regular photo right off the bat
it looks like the center is kind of this
really gray and washed out like it's
really too bright like the colors are
kind of gone I mean I've gotta I've got
to give it to the one on the right I
mean I love the contrast the trees you
got the darks everything pops nice and
detailed as well yeah the one in the
center is very very flat between the
left and the right they're both super
super close I'm actually gonna go with
the one on the left I like the
brightness and the saturation for me I
really like the one on the right very
close to the one on the very left but
the one in the middle is definitely is
way too bright the one on the right is
my first pick anyone all right let's see
right is pixel 7 Pro 15 Pro Max in the
middle wow it did the worst all right
then oh look at that a cat wow this
almost looks like a really far 10x shot
right here I really like the one on the
left which is because how crisp it is
okay I am actually gonna go for the
right oh funny I like how um I do like
how the cat kind of stands out more and
I do like how the colors of the eyes pop
out more than the center which is kind
of washed out that's funny I actually
like the one in the center oh um I don't
like I don't like the one on the left
it's a little too like over sharpened
and weird the center and the right are
both super close I like the blur they
look really natural but I feel like the
center one looks the most accurate to
real life if I were to be there in
person and we have we all chose
different ones so I got the iPhone on
the right pixel
all right we have a selfie look at that
they're very very similar they're really
good wow okay I'm actually going with
the right one right away I see the most
detail like his sweater his kind of
beard everything's super sharp looks
great I'm going for that one yeah I'm
gonna agree with you I really like the
one on the right
um the one on the left is the second
it's like little too bright this is
amazing on the right so Crystal Clear a
very much detail it's a killer one yep
oh wow 15. I did not expect that because
the s23 has a 40 megapixel compared to
12. I thought that was the interesting
that's 23. not bad all right we have oh
wow
look at that this is probably like a
crop from like far away or something
which one's the best definitely the
right the right the right okay yeah it's
got to be the right oh look at that
that's a huge crop s23 Ultra that's
probably because it's probably using the
200 megapixel I think compared to 48 and
pixel 7 Pros yeah not doing good all
right we got a portrait right here so it
looks like I don't know if this is a 3X
portrait or something but for me the one
on the right has probably the most true
colors in it pretty sharp really good
background versus the other ones I like
the one in the center the most if I look
at her hair there's the most detail in
it when the other ones are a little bit
crushed and I think the portrait worked
the best right here where it's it got
like all of her little hairs and then on
the left and the right it kind of messed
up a little bit and cuts them out that's
a good point I do see like a little bit
of mess up here a ton of issues right
over here and like her hair is black
it's gone I I also like the center I
like how it's got a little bit of a
yellowish glow to it oh oh man I think
I'm going with the 15 from Mexico next
up oh look at that feeling on the bed I
think this is a speed uh portrait on
each one right however it didn't work on
that did not work yeah yeah these are
very similar but I feel like there's the
most depth and detail on the one on the
left with all this concrete and stuff
when the center one looks a little bit
flat and washed out I actually agree I
like the left I'm with you on that but
I'm struggling between the left and the
center which is because of how one is
brighter than the other I would go with
the middle one all right well we both
chose 15 you chose s23 not bad oh wow
this very far
far portrait what in the world it's like
a really far portrait so with the amount
of blur be accurate it's a lot of or is
it too much because
compared to the other ones it looks like
a lot there's not much blurring oh yeah
you know on the right one at all and
that one looks really weird and like
artifacty oh yeah that's true I mean
honestly I'm gonna go with the left I
feel like there's too much blur and like
yeah some of the details it looks like
he was photoshopped onto like a
background or it was a DSLR I was really
Zoomed In from a really long distance I
would go with the middle one just
because how how his silhouette is so
um cutting through well you chose the
15. wow we both chose s23 whoa okay so
this is meant to go against the sun I
guess check out the flaring I mean I
gotta go with the one on the right yeah
you don't get that ring right here all
the colors are popping nicely and you
can see his face very well I'm done with
the right the left one really distracts
from the subject just how crazy the
flaring is but the right one looks so
crisp and so nice 100 with you guys yeah
it's a very clear crystal clear image
that is the 15 Pro Max wow it looks like
Apple's new feature where they got rid
of the lens flare is working quite well
for this one oh that's a far far shot
wow I would choose the one on the left
just for the amount of
um crispiness in it definitely yeah I
mean I I agree s23s 10x lens I mean it
kills it next up looks like we got
another portrait right here I think I
like the one in the center the most the
one on the right looks very weird and
unnatural I don't like how dark the one
in the center is but you can always
bring that up and I see a ton of detail
in her jacket that's lost in the left
one and I really like that this
foreground area is blurred yeah I mean
I'd have to agree with all those points
I love how this is blurred out and one
thing I noticed too if you look at her
jacket her coat and her face there's
highlight roll-off where it has a really
natural highlights and like Shadows or
here it's all just flat and same thing
kind of there so uh Center for me too I
have to disagree uh the one on the right
with me unfortunately guys I feel like
the colors represented uh best on the
right one yeah versus the left one has a
very similar look but a lot of details
have been lost let's see that's the
pixel yeah pretty good on colors all
right looks like we got almost like a
macro shot looks like it's using one of
the telephoto lenses what do you guys
think I mean one thing I noticed is I
feel like the highlights are blown out
kind of over the detail I feel like
there's a little details yeah probably
between left and right
actually I'm noticing more detail on the
left guys I'm going for that one yeah I
think I like the left one more because
he stands out a little more compared to
like the background we're on the right
one I'm looking way more on the ground
than I am at other guy like for me
personally on the right one I can see
both the asphalt and the background and
the the object itself the colors um it
just and you like that being able to see
the back yeah how clear it is now before
I reveal which phone is which I've got
to show you guys two of the best cases
you can buy for the iPhone 15 lineup
from our sponsor pataka both of these
have macsafe magnets built in and
they're weaved out of real aramid fiber
which is super strong yet very
lightweight especially their mag easy
case 4 Which is less than one millimeter
thick and so light it basically makes it
feel like you're not using a case at all
but you are and it's very strong
including a protective camera bump guard
now pataka's mag easy case Pro 4 is even
more tough and durable with a thicker
weave for ultimate shock resistance
wrapping all the way around all the
edges and buttons with a protruding rim
on the front to protect your display as
well and my favorite part is a super
tactile metal buttons to give it a very
premium look and feel so definitely
check these cases out and buy one today
by using the links in the description
below to get 10 off using Code Max Tech
10. alright let's reveal it and it looks
like you had the pixel we have the 15.
all right the next one looks like we
have a really close kind of like macro
shot the first thing I'm noticing is
that this Center area is in focus on
this one yeah but it's not on the others
it's just like these petals yeah I think
I'm gonna go with the left one also all
these little hairs and everything are
just so in focus on what look really
cool this one's extremely tough I think
I'm gonna go with the center I just like
how the edges of the flower are all like
really sharp I have to agree with
Angelica I completely agree that the the
center is perfectly
um in focus and you can see the details
on the leaves oh see you guys both got
the s23 wow the iPhone did not do well
in that one next up oh we got a far Zoom
shot look at that got some noise over
here on the left yeah yeah the middle is
kind of like smeared it is really soft
the one on the right is very detailed
very sharp yeah you guys like that one
yep yeah me too looks really really good
no noise and
pixel whoa the pixel one surprising it's
doing good oh cool we got another
portrait mode shot I don't know if this
is 1x or 3x but yeah it seems like the
center one is the portrait but the other
one
was more tricky yeah it's hard to say
what um was trying to achieve here for
the portrait absolutely the center yeah
the other ones look just a normal normal
photos normal mode yeah yeah I mean like
I think I gotta go off the center I mean
it just looks looks so much better plus
I love the glow on their hair 15. I
wonder if that's the 5x lens next up oh
we got another cool portrait shot right
away for me I'm not liking the center so
yeah that's the first thing I've seen
like some artifacts in his face and it's
insanely blue super blue super cool I
don't know what happened there yeah the
one on the left is absolutely the winner
though the center and the right are
close and quality but you can tell that
the one on the right is too way too warm
and the one in the middle is way too
cool and I'm seeing a ton of detail like
in the jeans that you did not get
interesting in the right photo and I I
really like the the highlights and the
contrast on his face like there's
Shadows when the one on the right is
very very flat I agree with you guys the
left is definitely the best and one
thing I also like is the depth kind of
roll-off you can see how it gets more
blurry as you get further away looks
really really easy I like that that's
the iPhone next up oh this looks like a
low light Zoom shot and honestly they
all look pretty terrible but one of them
looks better than the rest yeah it's the
center I mean what happened the left one
oh my goodness that's a massive fail it
looks like he's just fading yeah this is
oblivion it goes oh okay that's the crop
whoa s23 also failed it wow yep 15 for
Max is the best for this detail with HDR
that probably like smart hdr5 is working
right there oh wow look at that okay
this is okay like a long range Zoom here
or a crop man that one on the right
looks very not good oh it's like like
yeah
I'm going with the middle yeah I have to
go with the middle one the colors and
everything on the left is just super
purpley and you're losing like this is
all so smooth when you actually have
that detail that's the center yeah you
see the shadow lines and it's not like
all you can see the texture and her face
too you can see this is all blown out
kind of this is nice and like looks more
natural
oh that's a crop on the 15.
dang that's good next up we have a
selfie this looks like a evening
honestly for me no brainer the middle
definitely the middle definitely the
middle what is that oh what's the fifth
how is the 15 like once again it used to
lose in all the Selfies all the time oh
okay so we got a regular 1X looks like
no portraits definitely not the center
one in there
she's disappeared into the void to me
I'm going with the right I'm looking
closely and I see in his sweater tons of
like fiber details right yeah yep I'm
liking that one the best I I'm not a big
fan of the colors of the right one but
in terms of all the detail and
everything it definitely definitely
looks the best guys I'm sorry oh what
I'm going with the left one as much as I
agree about the uh DG tails on his
sweater Yep this kind of redness in the
middle feels a little bit artificial to
me yeah yeah
it's a little too um way too
oversaturated so I'm going with the left
one is because it's the most natural
looking one oh that's the 15. you got
the 50 yeah
that's 23 on the right next up oh
another kind of dark evening shot
no-brainer for me yeah remember the
second one look at the hair all the hair
you see how blurry yeah they're super
blurry this is super blown out almost
like motion oh look at the motion blur
on that one it's like it takes a while
to take the photo
oh my goodness this is crazy so the left
one is could work magic wow did you guys
see the tree details in the face oh my
goodness
and then not at all
what
15. oh that's probably why
I'm not surprised you're not surprised
yeah one thing that Apple said was there
they added
um stabilization to to periscope
telephoto camera that might be why the
night mode is working better okay we got
a 1x I think I'm really liking the one
on the right me too what are your
reasons for it um I want to say it is
just the equal amount of color yeah
exposure looks the most natural compared
to the other two yeah I I agree I'm not
a big fan of all of them but I think the
right one is the most balanced
oh that's the pixel wow oh got another
one okay okay wow okay this is ultra
wide at night if you look at the brick
wall
um disregarding everything else they are
very close yeah but then as true as you
start looking deeper into the shot how
much of the detail is lost and how
blurry this one gets and this one
um so yeah this one is difficult to
decide yeah the one on the right looks
very flat and faded and the colors just
don't look natural like Shadows
shouldn't have a color to them the one
in the center I really like that the
brick has like a ton of detail if you
look at this little poster you can see
little lines where the words are this
one's a little smeary the center one's
super detailed and sharp I mean I gotta
agree I like the center one especially
since the highlights are not as blown
out here for the sign and it's kind of
like sharp I like that 100 with you guys
that's the pixel again wow all right huh
yeah they all have their flaws I think
I'm gonna have to go with the center one
you can see the most detail there are
Parts in the left one that are detailed
and then there's other parts that are
completely crushed so it's like a big
drastic shift in that the center one you
can see a good amount but it still looks
like a nighttime photo it doesn't look
daytime I mean for me I don't like the
center because I just feel like there's
blotchiness like all this artifacts
everywhere I feel like the right one is
way too dark while being blown out I'm
going for the left even though it's not
that good I think it's the best I also
like that it's not blown out here so you
can see the details on the inside here
compared to the left one
[Laughter]
so I I was gonna go 100 with the left
one at first but then as I looked deeper
I I changed my mind and it's gonna be
the right oh we all tasted even though
even though it's not enough light but I
want to say it's very
um natural looking one it's out of the
three that's the one I would put on uh
on a wall like a like a photo well let's
see yeah you chose the pixel again I
chose the iPhone
so we got probably a zoom shot here
right off the bat the left one I'm going
with the left as well I love how the
color of the lamp kind of shows off
everything in general looks looks pretty
good it's a little bit warm but I hate
all of the over sharpening right there
yeah the one on the right is very smudgy
very blurry the center one looks almost
artifacty to me the one on the left yeah
it's it's pretty warm but it looks the
most detailed and smooth and realistic
and balanced the left one is absolutely
gorgeous yeah it's a good photo oh wow
iPhone again whoa
is this Ultra wide or main it might be
ultra white I mean I I feel like I'm
going for the right because I'm seeing a
lot of detail on the bridge down here
all the textures I like the colors yeah
it's the most crushed down here however
the the details of everything is just
Way Beyond the other two the one on the
on the right
oh wow
[Music]
yeah this is really blown out huh so
good super blow now and then there's so
much detail that's lost like in the
darkness I'm impressed how much you can
see here and in the sky and everything
and it looks so natural too
wow just back and forth portrait right
for me it's definitely the one on the
left the one on the right way too much
detail is lost because it's way too dark
like her hair her jacket she just kind
of disappears the one in the center even
though it's a portrait it's so
incredibly flat the one on the left
there's so much like detail in her face
everything looks very natural very
realistic I would go with the left one
because how natural it is yeah me too
all those things s23 okay so we got a
kind of Zoom portrait here no-brainer
for me right it's definitely the most
detailed I really like the hair all that
detail and like the the brightness and
the highlights when the other two are a
little smudgy yeah the other two were
kind of soft it's a good one pixel wow
wow it's like going back and forth all
over the place it's crazy
[Music]
I mean definitely not the middle not the
pink ones it's a Barbie color yeah yeah
they're very close so I guess it just
goes down to personal preference but I
like how the left one pops
I'm actually gonna choose the right one
guys because I looked really closely at
this Gourmet Burgers and Brews I kind of
like how it looks a little bit more
so I'm just put them around
oh wow pixel you guys got the 15. whoa
okay it's getting really dark super dark
thank you I think the center one is the
best in the scenario one thousand
percent I think so yeah 15. all right
some low light first glance I was gonna
go with the white one but then as I
started looking Ian I've noticed a lot
of green the cloth looks a little way
too sharp like over sharpened by
processing the one on the left looks the
most the most organic I agree actually
yeah I did notice the whole over
sharpening here too it's kind of like
bothering me when I look at it so left
as well yeah it was very tough to decide
between the left and the right they're
both super super close but I agree
wow oh
like a pretty
shot wow wow there's so much detail on
the right one that is
yeah crisp the center one looks like
there's almost like motion blur even
though there shouldn't be same same yeah
is that right one looks yeah this almost
looks like a pro camera incredibly good
wow that's crazy
oh this is a far far shot right here I
mean to me I like the left man yeah it's
it's a little too bright in my opinion
but it's still better than the rest
though better than that that's for sure
[Music]
and that's it that was the last one
there were 35 photos in total so we're
gonna write down and count how much we
got all right guys if you played along
with us count up your tallies comment
down below which one won but here's what
we got Johnny I got
um 18 for the iPhone 15. six four s23
Ultra and 11 for the pixel nice yeah I
actually got pretty close we got 21 for
the iPhone five only five for the s23
nine for the pixel and for me I got 20
for the iPhone 8 for the s23 and seven
for the pencil so those are very very
close swapped them around interesting so
it looks like so far at least for us the
iPhone is doing quite well with that new
5x lens smart hdr5 and it took the lead
that was a lot of fun Angelica thank you
Johnny thank you it was a blast so
hopefully you enjoyed this video let us
know your thoughts down below click the
button above to subscribe and check out
one of those two videos right over there
thank thanks for watching this has been
Vadim Angelica and Johnny and we'll see
you in the next one
foreign